et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean-baptiste lemoyne bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous aux
tatars d'état chargé du tourisme des
français de l'étranger et de la
francophonie on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre redon bonjour fredrik
bonjour au riad pour jour les journaux
du groupe ebra ce sont les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france que vous
connaissez bien jean baptiste lemoyne
on commence par l'international et par
ce voyage d'emmanuel macro hier au
rwanda un génocide ne s'excuse pas un
pardon ne saisissent pas c'est ce qu'a
dit le président de la république mais
il a reconnu des responsabilités de la
france pour ce qu'elle est des
associations de victimes se disent déçus
s en attendaient plus du président de la
république à l attendait des excuses
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin est ce
qu'il faut aborder la question des
réparations maintenant et je crois que
déjà le geste qu'ils aient lieu hier il
était très fort il était empreint de
gravité de solennité
c'est pas mince que cette reconnaissance
de responsabilité justement la
responsabilité aussi
au delà de la france la communauté
internationale pendant plusieurs mois
mais quelque part elle a pas été au
rendez vous à cette époque bon et donc
moi je retiens surtout que le président
d'ailleurs du rwanda monsieur kagame a
accueilli le la déclaration le discours
du président de la république justement
en exprimant le courage qu'il
reconnaissait cette déclaration donc je
crois que il a dit en gros c'était même
mieux que des excuses il a dit comme ça
donc je crois que clairement c'est une
nouvelle page qui s'écrit dans la
relation entre la france et le rwanda
entre nos jeunesses aussi parce que
finalement le président la république ma
génération nous avions quoi 15 16 ans à
ce moment là et la jeunesse du rwanda
jeunesse française bon il faut avoir en
tête l'histoire justement il faut ne
rien oublier
il faut comprendre mais aujourd'hui la
france avec le rwanda l'europe avec
l'afrique
on a de belles et grandes choses à faire
nous sommes quelque part unie dans dans
nos destins regardez nous sommes un peu
ce grand fuseau qui se tient nous sommes
à 14 kilomètres l'un de l'autre ces deux
continents et donc on a énormément de
défis à relever gérer un certain nombre
de conflits aussi qu'ils peuvent avoir
des répercussions du continent africain
sur le continent européen
et puis aussi c'était ça aussi le
discours de emmanuel macron c'était une
manière de réaffirmer la place de la
france sur le continent
c'est comme ça aussi qu'il faut
l'interpréter or le discours du
président il s'inscrit aussi dans c'est
un fils qu'ils tirent depuis plusieurs
années depuis qu'il est entré en
fonction il a souhaité aussi je dirais
faire en sorte que les jeunesse se
parlent plus que les sociétés civiles se
parlent plus et d'ailleurs
le sommet afrique france qui se tiendra
en octobre prochain à montpellier
il va être très orientée autour autour
justement de ces liens de jeunesse de
diaspora et donc revisiter un peu donné
je crois un nouveau départ à 7 à cette
relation et donc sur la question des
réparations vous dit tu sais pas c'est
pas le moment c'est pas l'heure c'est
pas la question je crois que aujourd'hui
le sujet il était clairement cette
reconnaissance après il ya un certain
nombre de procédures de justice qui
naturellement sont en cours ben voilà
avant dans la recherche des coupables
présumés coupables et des finances
la justice elle doit doit passer pour
suivre les génocidaires qui en a
certains qui se trouvent en france j'ai
mis d'ailleurs il ya des procédures qui
sont ouverts donc je crois que la
justice doit faire son travail
là on est dans autre chose on est dans
dans un travail mémoriel et c'est vrai
que le président de la république veille
à réconcilier les mémoires des mémoires
qui parfois sont antagonistes
mais qui pour autant doivent pouvoir
dialoguer ensemble il le fait s'agissant
du rwanda avec la commission du clair
parce que sa prise de parole vient aussi
après tout un travail de documentation
et et d'ailleurs nous allons continuer à
encourager la recherche sur ces thèmes
là il le fait également s'agissant de la
relation avec l'algérie
vous le savez avec le rapport stora donc
voilà c'est sa marque de fabrique aussi
je crois bien que de vouloir réconcilier
les mémoires et que voilà je crois que
certaines forces et 10 sport très
contemporaine en réalité est ce que ce
qui s'est passé pour le grand date
pourrait encore se produire aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue français j'entends
c'est ce que les pouvoirs politiques
français sont organisés différemment
fonctionne différemment suffisamment
différemment pour que ça ne se
reproduise plus a je pense quand même il
faut toujours être instruits du passé
tirer les leçons de tout cela et il est
déjà et j'espère aider et j'espère quand
même que aujourd'hui il y aurait de la
clairvoyance sont bien sûr la crise
sanitaire et le développement du variant
bien qui inquiète des mesures ont été
prises envers le royaume uni face au
développement de ce variant dire mesures
de quarantaine à ce qu'à d'autres
mesures qui sont à l'étude alors
aujourd'hui ce qu'on souhaite c'est
pouvoir faire en sorte de préserver la
france d'une nouvelle vague et donc ça
veut dire parce qu'on est en train
progressivement de deux de haut se
réouvrir réouvrir notre économie on a eu
l'étape du 3 mai puis du 19 mai on est
en train de préparer celle du 9 juin les
chiffres sont encourageants vous l'avez
vu les baisses à la fois de nouveaux cas
d'hospitalisation de réanimation bref
tout ça va dans le bon sens maintenant
la relance ça rime aussi avec la
prudence et la vigilance et c'est
pourquoi nous sommes très attentifs à
l'évolution des variants et notamment de
ce variant indien
on a vu combien en inde il avait pu
provoquer et bien de dégâts et la france
une star en thèse mais a contribué à un
effort de solidarité vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires indiens en faisant un vrai
pont aérien et maritime d'oxygène parce
qu'ils en avaient vraiment besoin et je
reviens à la situation au royaume uni
dès lors que il ya effectivement cette
situation avec quelques milliers de cas
qui sont manifestés et surtout on voit
une très grande transmissibilité de ce
variant est bien de prendre des
précautions les précautions c'est de
renforcer les tests qui sont exigés
c'est à dire demander que ces tests
étaient moins de 48 heures nos français
établis hors de france parce que c'est
une grosse communauté ils pourront
naturellement toujours revenir sur le
sol français ça
7 c'est leur droit le plus sacré on leur
demande juste de faire ce test qui peut
ête antigénique d'ailleurs donc c'est
important ce que ta santé unix comme
très pratique très facile en 15 minutes
vous avez le résultat en revanche pour
les non ressortissants français
la la le déplacement est conditionné au
motif impérieux donc c'est à dire que
les motifs impérieux c'est une liste qui
est assez restrictive
ça veut dire qu'on ne vient pas en
loisir si je puis dire on ne vient pas
en vacances et donc moi j'espère que le
royaume uni va pouvoir juguler ce
variant indien le plus vite possible et
pour le moment c'est le seul pays qui
vous inquiète ou est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres pays qui pourraient être qu'ils
pourraient subir les mêmes mesures que
subit ce que je subis le royaume uni
depuis on a une surveillance généralisée
avec nos amis européens
et d'ailleurs on travaille dans le cadre
de la réouverture à partir du 9 juin du
tourisme international
on travaille avec les européens à
établir une liste alors il ya la liste
des pays vers les pays dans lesquels la
situation sanitaire permet de relancer
les flux sans motif impérieux et donc
c'est une première liste il y aura une
liste de pays
entre guillemets rouge c'est-à-dire où
la situation sanitaire fait que on
maintiendra des motifs impérieux et puis
entre deux des pays sur lesquels on
demandera un certain nombre de
précautions et donc on est au travail là
dessus et on la connaîtra quand c'est
triste parce qu'elle est attendue par
beaucoup de gens maintenant cette liste
tout à fait alors déjà ce travail qu'on
fait en européens pour se coordonner au
maximum le cdc européen doit nous donner
un certain nombre d'éléments pour
pouvoir arrêter cette liste sachant que
les états membres aussi pour on l'adapté
ici ou là c'est pour ça que c'est très
important de se parler entre collègues
européens parce qu'il peut exister des
tentations de certains d'ouvrir
peut-être plus largement que ce que la
majorité souhaiterait ça veut dire qu'il
ya des divergences au sein de l'union
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que le
dialogue il est il est franc et parfois
viril pour dire les choses voilà qui non
mais on voit bien qu'un certain nombre
de pays du sud je pense à l'espagne au
portugal à la grèce ont cette tentation
de d'ouvrir vite et fort nous pensons
qu'il faut garder encore une fois une
certaine vigilance et prudence parce que
en réalité si on prend le tourisme c'est
le tourisme international
en france comme en espagne ou en italie
il est quand même aux deux tiers le fait
est bien des clientèles européennes
elles-mêmes
donc on a en nous même je dirais un
socle domestique qui est important et
nous permettra de relancer sur la date
la date de cette liste ça sera quand
j'écoutais ça sera je pense sous
dizaines et dizaines de jours
voilà il faut que nous aboutissions pour
pouvoir être prêt au 9 juin pour vous et
dizaine de jours voilà vous dis c'est
dans l'avenir on espère pouvoir
finaliser cette liste bien sûr c'est
quand même la quadrature du cercle pour
vous parce que la tentation en france au
cidre ouvrir et d'inviter des européens
et non européens
notre clientèle à revenir parce que le
tourisme est quand même on évoque
toujours à l'épée du sud l'italie
l'espagne et la france est un grand pays
sur écrans pétrolier d'ailleurs en
termes d'attractivité internationale et
donc alors vous mettez le curseur ou
alors nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est
relance mais mes relances et vigilance
donc relance ont fait une grande
campagne européenne avec atout france
avec les régions les territoires on met
10 millions d'euros sur la table en vous
allez chercher des tories on va chercher
des touristes européens europe et
européens parce que c'est c'est un socle
très fort c'est les deux tiers aux trois
quarts des clientèles internationales
je peux vous dire d'ailleurs que l'été
dernier j'avais été les chercher même à
la frontière je me souviens des belges
dès la réouverture et la france avaient
d'ailleurs mieux résisté que l'espagne
que l'italie on avait entre guillemets
perdu que 50 % de recettes
internationales là où j'en avais perdu
75% et donc avec cette campagne de
promotion on entend bien j'entends bien
que l'été bleu blanc rouge qui qui qui
qui et je dirai bons mots clés se
décline dans toutes les langues en
allemand néerlandais
on va parler de cette question du
tourisme pomy dans quelques secondes
mais j'ai juste encore deux questions
pratiques sur les réouvertures et
justement les des circulations entre les
pays à l'heure actuelle quand on vient
d'un pays hors de l'union européenne on
est soumis à un isolement de sept jours
c'est ça qui est qui est obligatoire
est ce que dans les jours à venir les
personnes qui sont vaccinées ne seront
plus soumis à cet isolement et même pour
toutes les personnes il sera levé quand
cet isolement de sept jours alors je
vous rends en fait on est en train de
travailler sur un jeu comme je le disais
sur ses listes de pays vert rouge et
entre deux oranges si je puis dire
et après au sein de ces différentes
catégories de pays
quels sont les pré requis pour pénétrer
sur sol européen et français
selon qu' on est vaccinés ou pas il ya
sept
il ya cette question du du pass
sanitaire du certificat vert numérique
européen montré que bien
soit on est vaccinés soit on a un test
négatif soit on est immunisé
donc on est vraiment à la tâche à dessus
et peut-être si on évalue sondés y aura
plus d'isolement c'est ça ah ben il faut
les enfin qu'on soit vacciné d'ailleurs
ou qu'on produise un test pcr négatif
quand on vient d'un pays vers bien que
quand on arrive il faut plus d'isolement
sinon il ya tout simplement plus de
tourisme possible donc c'est ça
l'intérêt aussi de classer les pays sur
l'eau selon leur état sanitaire c'est
d'avoir des contraintes qui sont plus ou
moins fortes
et naturellement on espère bien
accueillir les clientèles des pays vert
et je l'espère de mon côté des pays
aussi orange
je pense par exemple aux clientèles
américaines le président d'un public
d'ailleurs a émis le souhait qu'on
puisse accueillir ces clientèles dès le
mois de juin il s'était adressé à
adresser aux américains sur cbs c'était
chez vos confrères mi-avril et je peux
vous dire que depuis on a vu un rebond
dans les réservations des américains qui
dès le mois de juin soit de venir en
france et d'ailleurs font des
réservations c'est très encourageant
pour l'arrière saison et c'est très
important pour des territoires comme
paris comme la côte d'azur qui l'année
dernière ont souffert de l'absence des
clientèles internationales soit c'est de
redémarrer le tourisme à l'international
dès le 9 juin à l'international sur les
pays sur les pays émetteurs dont la
situation sanitaire le permet encore une
fois on
il faut pas faire n'importe quoi parce
que les prochaines du tourisme je vous
dire que ils ont souffert aussi de ces
différentes vagues et maintenant que
j'irai ouvre il souhaiterait ouvrir de
façon pérenne et donc c'est aussi la
responsabilité de tous de faire
attention et justement par le tourisme
aïssaoui avec des nouveautés notamment
cette explosion du camping
qui a priori tu va doubler sa
fréquentation l'année prochaine
les prochains les prochaines semaines qu
il explique d'ailleurs ce bond en avant
du camping alors on a déjà vu ses
tendances à l'oeuvre
l'été dernier les campings et fait de
beaux résultats
et peut-être quelques éléments efficient
pour accréditer ce que ce que ce que
vous évoquez c'est que dans depuis un
mois les campings sont à plus 100 % de
réservations par rapport aux années
précédentes donc c'est énorme
considérable moi je tire mon chapeau à
tous ces professionnels de l'hôtellerie
de plein air je travaille beaucoup et
nicolas bayod qui le président de la
fédération nationale et je peux vous
dire que il reste pas les deux pieds
dans le même sabot is enough irait nov
ils font évoluer leur leur établissement
avec toujours plus de confort avec
beaucoup d'activités et ce sont ce sont
des gens très courageux et je peux vous
dire que effectivement les français
reprennent bien volontiers le chemin de
deux de ses espaces étaient favorables
haute les nerfs mais pour exactement
pour des réseaux et mixé pour des
raisons sanitaires ces questions est en
fait en fait je crois que tout
simplement ils souhaitent aussi de plus
rester en france que par le passé parce
que finalement on est bien chez soi et
les jeux et je confirme pas ce que vous
pouvez faire le tour du monde en faisant
le tour de france tellement il ya une
diversité de paysages une variété à la
fois de patrimoine etc
je crois que en france c'est unique vous
pouvez trouver 50 nuance de vacances
voilà il s'est pas partout il ya des
destinations ailleurs dans le monde qui
sont quand même très très centré sur un
produit nous il ya vraiment bas pour
tous les goûts et pour toutes les
bourses
ça veut dire que ce matin vous dit aux
français restés passer vos vacances en
france cet été
dans tous les cas je suis pas dans les
injections parce que les français ils en
ont soupé des injonctions et des
contraintes mais ce que je leur dise et
j'ai mangé les convaincre que la france
c'est le meilleur choix
voilà parce qu'encore une fois ils en
prendront plein les mirettes et en plus
y'a plein de plein de comment dire de
territoire peut-être encore trop
méconnus ou au sein de territoires très
visitée plein de pépites encore à
découvrir et vous receviez auparavant 1
parlementaires de la région sud par
exemple françois de canson le président
du du crt de la région sud
hier justement présentait un certain
nombre de nouveaux parcours qui vont
être mis en avant par la région sud pour
inciter bien sortir des sentiers battus
mais ça veut dire que vous travaillez
avec les collectivités territoriales
pour attirer les touristes français dans
leur région dans les régions voisines
avec atout france nous avons lancé une
campagne qui s'appelle avec un hashtag
je redécouvre la france 1
et l'idée c'est justement est bien de
les inciter à rester ici et encore une
fois alors je suis conscient que nous
avons des professionnels du tourisme qui
sont également orientés vers l'envoi de
touristes français vers l'étranger
notamment toutes les agences de voyages
d'entreprise du voyage est donc ce que
je veux leur dire c'est que
naturellement nous continuer à être à
leurs côtés parce que eux en termes de
réservations ça repart mais c'est quand
même effectivement plus faible que par
le passé et donc on va maintenir nos
dispositifs de soutien aux acteurs du
tourisme qui continua plus souffrir que
les autres et d'ailleurs bruno le maire
du soft ont annoncé hier ceux des
mesures du collectif budgétaire et un
milliard d'euros 2,2 de soutien encore
aux secteurs les plus touchés
donc ça s'adresse à aussi à venir
jusqu'à quand justement est-ce que les
mesures du soutien des gens qui vivent
du tourisme notamment du tourisme
international et elles vont être
maintenues ah bah déjà que les touristes
étrangers qu'on a fait venir en masse on
a fait la preuve depuis 14 mois qu'on a
toujours su adapter les dispositifs et
les maintenir
et donc là on maintient plus pour le
secteur du tourisme international à
laleu
on fait en sorte que juin juillet août
septembre pourrait secteurs les plus
impactés on soit encore en rendez vous
avec le fonds de solidarité alors qu'ils
évoluent d'ailleurs qui est plus
facilement accessible en terme de perte
de chiffre d'affaires et puis on
compense mais de façon décroissante les
pertes avec l'activité partielle elle
aussi avec des restes à charge qui vont
progressivement augmenté mais quand même
on est encore là donc voilà je crois que
le secteur du tourisme
il est une priorité nationale c'était
clairement établie par le président de
république par le premier ministre le
premie cela l'a montré hier et nous
étions en déplacement justement en
savoie à bourg saint maurice et aux arcs
pour évoquer l'avenir de la montagne
française parce que vous vous dire que
ça fait bien longtemps que des
gouvernements n'avaient pas mis autant
non seulement de moyens mais également
d'outils pour le tourisme en france sur
la fréquentation pour fermer le chapitre
est ce que paris compte tenu ces deux
nouvelles pratiques ces nouveaux goûts
est ce que paris peut perdre son statut
de première destination touristique
française paris moi je suis je suis
confiant sur le fait que paris est une
destination qui sera résiliente
mais elle a besoin de retrouver ses
clientèles internationales et c'est là
où on voit que ça va être le cas pour
les américains ça va être le cas pour
quelques clients internationale mais les
clientèles asiatiques qui sont très
importantes vont mettre plus de temps à
revenir on voit bien que du côté des
chinois c'est pas avant la fin de
l'année le début de l'année prochaine on
voit qu'elles sont de votre fête
religieuse en réalité en réalité en asie
on le voit les procédures de d'admission
ou du réadmission dans ces pays sont
ultra contraignante ultra contraignantes
ces cdd 14/n qui durent parfois trois
semaines donc c'est vous dire ce que
c'est donc en réalité ça ça tue toute
velléité de tourisme international
mais ils nous ont bon espoir que à
partir de 2022 ce moteur des clientèles
asiatiques repartira on va parler de la
montagne puisque vous le disais vous
étiez hier en savoie pour le plomb
montanes 650 millions d'euros qui ont
été annoncés par jean castex quand les
professionnels en verront-ils
concrètement la couleur de cet argent
alors j'espère très vite au sens où
maintenant on a donné des outils pour
que les acteurs de la montagne puisse
lancer des investissements et je les dis
d'ailleurs au président des domaines
skiables de france alexandre mollahs des
outils qui notamment sont très
intéressants parce que on mobilise des
fonds d'épargné de la caisse des dépôts
qui permettent d différé de
remboursement de 5 ans donc ça veut dire
que vous pouvez investir ne rien payer
en mensualités pendant cinq ans et donc
ça permet de soutenir aussi tout ce
qu'on appelle l'amour l'amont c'est quoi
c'est ces professionnels les paumes
aller mnd etc qui sont une vraie filière
d'excellence de la france d'ailleurs
notamment à l'export et qui sont bien
celles et ceux qui permettent domaines
skiables français d'être d'être au top
niveau
donc aujourd'hui cet argent ça y est il
est annoncé il est là il est prêt à être
engagés et pour être engagé il faut
aussi que les territoires mûrissent des
projets donc on a mis en place aussi
avec joël giraud des crédits dédiés à
l'ingénierie pour faire mûrir le projet
m'aimait tout et tout est prêt et est
désormais les investissements peuvent se
faire je le souhaite dès cet été
et tout cela vient je dirais en plus de
5 milliards d'euros
dead d'urgence qu'on a mis en place
depuis le mois de décembre
parce qu'effectivement la montagne
française a connu un choc quand je suis
à l'érable il vient de pertes
10 milliards de pertes c'est
l'estimation qui a été fait
certains élus effectivement ça lui
beaucoup d'élus salue les aides incrites
annoncé hier
mais ça reste très partiel par rapport
aux 10 milliards qui ont été faites vous
dire enfin parler aux professionnels du
tourisme
écoutez les j'ai écouté certains de vos
confrères ce matin eux ils disent merci
ils disent merci parce qu'ils savent que
ils n'auraient pas tenu le choc si on
n'avait pas mis en place tous ces dites
vous énervez mélenchon quand même on va
avoir besoin de plus est-ce qu'il est
second plan kéké en prévision est ce
qu'il y aura d'autres d'autre part dont
moi j'aime bien que on n'a pas engagé le
premier euro d'un plan de 650 millions
d'euros de crédits nouveaux qui vont
générer un milliard huit
d'investissement quand on compose la
question du deuxième plan enfin déjà
dépensons et investissons tout ce qui
est prévu et puis après la montagne on
la laisse pas tomber et d'ailleurs les
acteurs le savent on est avec joël dire
on a fait le tour de france des massifs
on continuera et moi je suis très
attentif à la montagne parce que c'est
une composante essentielle du tourisme
tricolore est d'ailleurs la montagne je
peux vous dire qu'elle a pris des
couleurs l'été dernier et je pense que
l'été qui s'annonce ça serait aussi un
très bel été pour la montagne
on l'a vu en échangeant hier avec les
acteurs du tourisme aux arcs
il ya book eh bien ils nous disent aussi
en termes de réservations il voit
énormément de réservations se faire
parce que justement l'idée c'est aussi
de cette montagne
elles deviennent quatre saisons
naturellement les activités ce qui
demeure très importante il faut pas leur
tourner le dos mais il faut aussi
maintenant avec les vélos à assistance
électrique etc
il ya de nouvelles offres de nouvelles
activités qui sont possibles les
dernières questions de fabrice qu'une
politique sur votre ancienne famille
évidemment les républicains février vous
gardez un oeil quand même sur cette
cette droite d'où vous venez
notamment les régionales dans quelques
jours bon déjà quel regard porté sur 7
sur votre ancienne famille politique
et puis un petit mot sur ses alliances
qui peuvent se nouer ci est là notamment
en bourgogne franche comté
gilles platret qui se rapproche de
debout la france ça vous inspire quoi
bah écoutez c'est une droite en fait qui
a un peu perdu sa boussole passe quand
on le voit
on a désormais
des membres au sein d air qui font des
alliances à géométrie variable
alors que la boussole des créateurs de
l'ump de jacques chirac elle était clair
été clair pas de compromission j'irai
étanchéité totale vis-à-vis l'extrême
droite et on voit que gilles platret par
exemple il a tendance à s'affranchir de
cela renaud muselier al'inverse a fait
le choix courageux de rassembler de
réunir et donc on le soutient la
majorité présidentielle le soutien et je
trouve que c'était courageux de le faire
c'était la bonne méthode aba en tous les
cas c'est l'union la plus large qui à
mon avis permet d'avoir le meilleur élan
possible rien n'aurait été pire
alors que franchement renaud muselier
c'est un président de région qui a un
bon bilan moi je le vois sur le tourisme
on travaille ensemble très étroitement
et donc sur sur les valeurs on est on
est quand même d'accord sur l'essentiel
voilà donc après naturellement il ya des
nuances sur le projet de transformation
que portel macron depuis cinq ans c'est
pas le même projet que ce que portait ce
que portent les républicains mais en
revanche au niveau local on le voit on
le voit dans les conseils municipaux
dans les conseils départementaux ou
régionaux
quand il s'agit de gérer les lycées les
trains et c'est à dire c'est pas une
question de droite de gauche ou de
centre avancé des questions de bon sens
et donc sur le bon sens on peut se
rassembler et merci beaucoup merci jean
vaz les moines d'avoir été notre invité
fabrice de regarder la une du dauphiné
puisqu'elle va vous intéresser jean
baptiste le mandat d'arrêt on parle on
parle de tourisme bien sûr et avec
notamment le ministre du tourisme
régionaux du groupe ebra destination
france est donc à la une d du dauphiné
et des journaux du groupe ebra merci
jean baptiste leur série
[Musique]